(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer,
and tonight
guest shark LORI Greiner
joins the tank.
I treat all of my products
as though they were my babies.
Hopeful entrepreneurs come
to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
How many have you sold?
50.
(Kevin and daymond) WHOA!
(chuckles) Dang.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money...
I like cash flow.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You have to ignore them.
Tv ladies are
a dime a dozen.
You just sit back
and watch me make me money.
I've been doing retail
for 25 years and branding.
I've forgotten more
than she has learned.
Oh, come on.
That was nasty.
But first the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
This is not a good idea.
Shh!
It's sink
or swim.
I want to play with winners.
Who are the sharks?
They're five
powerful, self-Made investors
worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 billion.
Lori Greiner is the queen
of qvc.
She holds 108 patents and has
launched over 300 products
grossing $500 million
in Worldwide retail sales.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-Shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec,
the son of
an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-Made,
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas mavericks.
♪♪♪
My name is Barbara lampugnale,
and I live
in west Hartford, connecticut.
I am a mother of six girls,
two of which have gone off
to college.
(chuckles)
My girls and I absolutely love
doing Fun things together,
so on Sunday nights,
it's become tradition that
we all get together
and paint each other's nails.
Do my toesies.
It was on one
of these nail nights
where my idea just hit me.
Wow.
With the economy being
the way that it is,
it's been really tough.
We've had such struggles,
coming very close
to losing our house.
I've gone so far as to, um...
(chuckles)
Sell my engagement ring,
and we've just invested
what we could
into this business.
We have come to a point
where we're at the end
of our resources,
and an investment
from the sharks
will truly change the lives
of my family.
♪♪♪
My name is
Barbara lampugnale,
and I'm the owner
of duality cosmetics.
I am so excited to share
with you today
my revolutionary, new product,
the nail Pak.
I am asking for $50,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my company.
I am a mother
of six daughters.
Traditionally,
on Sunday nights in our house,
it's what we call
"Nail night."
It's where my daughters
and I all gather
and we paint
each other's nails.
On one of these nights, I took
a common nail polish bottle,
put it on top
of a small plastic container,
and the inspiration hit me.
This... was too much stuff.
The nail polish, the pads,
the remover, and the files--
All...
(clatters)
Too much stuff,
So, voila, the idea
for the nail Pak was born.
I thought, what could be
more convenient and simple
than putting
all four of those things--
The nail polish, the pads,
the remover, and the file--
In one easy-to-Use container?
The nail Pak has 0.8 ounces
of nail polish on the top.
When you remove it
from the bottom,
it has a nail file.
When you pull this tab,
you will find cotton pads
that are pre-Moistened
with nail polish remover.
With the nail Pak,
we can make changing
your manicure
as easy as changing
your mind.
What about the pricing
on this?
Tell me what it costs
to make one bottle
and how much
you sell it for.
Right now, because I'm only
doing a run of 10,000,
it's just a little over $3.
$3.
And what do you sell it for?
$14.99.
Ooh. I like those margins.
So would the average woman
think that's expensive,
the $14.99?
I don't believe so,
not in, um, some
of the cosmetic-Type stores.
It's right on par,
but you're also getting
a 3-in-1 value.
Right. C-Could I see it?
Yeah, can I see it, too?
Oh, absolutely.
I'm so sorry.
When did you apply
for your patent?
Approximately
nine months ago.
Did you check to see
if anybody else has made
anything else like this?
Absolutely. The--the money that
I've paid my patent attorney,
he'd better have done all
of that and more. (chuckles)
And--and there was
nothing out there like this
that he could find?
Absolutely nothing.
How much do you have
invested, Barbara?
Personally,
we've invested about--
Just under $300,000.
(Kevin and daymond) WHOA!
(mark chuckles) Dang.
And do you have
any outside investors?
Not yet.
$300,000?
It's just me. Yes.
(Robert) Wow.
It's the manufacturing.
I'm sure Lori could attest
to that.
Yeah. That's--That's
a lot of cash, Barbara.
What do you do for a living?
I'm a stay-at-Home mom
currently. (laughs)
And you just saved it
all up over time?
It--
Well, my husband is
a real estate developer,
so for quite a long time,
we were doing very well.
And actually
that's why I'm here now,
because the last
couple years,
it's been extremely challenging
for our family.
Barbara, do you have any channel
in distribution or retail
that's agreed to take it on
or give you an order?
I have really just started
talking to them
within the last month,
'cause I find with the products
that you can explain it
and it sounds like
a really great idea,
but until you actually
see it, feel it, touch it,
it makes--
It has such a wow factor
to it.
So your premise of demand
is based on
your own family experience,
your six daughters and yourself
on Nail night sundays.
Are those all
your own daughters?
The--Every single one
of 'em.
Well, you look terrific.
Thank you. Good genes.
(laughs)
(Robert laughs)
(laughs) What--what--
are you gonna date her
or invest in her?
I'm just--I'm just saying...
Yeah, right.
But--But I want--
I don't think
my italian Husband would
like that very much.
(Robert) Yeah.
(Lori) Dream on. Come on.
Yeah.
(Kevin) the premise
of this brand is not necessarily
the quality
of the nail polish itself.
It's the convenience factor
that you're providing
by putting the pads
underneath the bottle.
I'm not saying it's bad.
Mm-hmm.
I'm just wondering,
where's the proof?
You know, I'm
a skeptical investor, Barbara.
I see.
I want to know that
it's gonna work,
not just
because your six daughters
and yourself had a great time
on a Sunday night with it.
Right.
Now if this doesn't work,
you've blown $300,000, right?
But I don't look
at it negatively like that.
No, no.
I'm not trying to be negative.
(mark) And you shouldn't.
And you know what?
You shouldn't, right?
Right.
Barbara, I can't add
any value with this.
I mean, the--the thought
of spending $300,000
before you have orders...
Mm-Hmm.
Wow, you gotta have
some, uh, guts to do that.
This isn't an investment
for me. I'm out.
Barbara,
the challenge I have
is that right now
it's just you, right,
and so you're gonna need
a big support team
in order to get it
where you need to go.
I'm not the guy
to help you build
that infrastructure
and support team
to go out
and sell this product,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
It's great that
you got to this point,
but I don't know
if it sells.
You know what I need?
I want some distribution.
What are you gonna do
with this, Lori?
What am I gonna do with it?
Yeah.
(laughs) What are you gonna
do with it, Kevin?
No, but if you told me
you were gonna put it on qvc,
I might get interested
in funding some of it.
That's my point.
It needs distribution.
Well, here's the thing.
If I'm gonna put it in on qvc,
I'm not gonna need your help.
Well, maybe you do...
exactly.
Because you have
the same risk I have.
Why?
Well, look, you may be
a greedy Savage,
but you may make
a big mistake.
(chuckles)
I'm not worried about it.
I'm not worried about what--
you tell him, Lori.
If I decide to go in on this,
I can do it myself.
Well, then what are
you doing?
Because maybe
what I'll do is--
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Then I may have to bid you up.
I'll make you pay more.
I'm telling you...
I'm not afraid.
Don't mess
with Mr. Wonderful.
I-I'm not--
(mark)
he's all talk and no bite.
I'm not worried.
You--You just sit back
and watch me make me money.
Let's see.
There you go.
Let's see what happens.
Okay.
All right, so I like this.
Thank you.
I can do millions
of this for you
on qvc and everywhere else.
So here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you the $50,000,
and I want 51%
in the company...
(scoffs)
Wow.
Because I'm gonna take this,
and tomorrow morning,
you and I are gonna get
on the phone
and we're gonna strategize
what we're gonna do immediately
with the 10,000 units that
you already have sitting there.
I will get that on my show.
We will launch it.
We will be a huge success,
and I give you one condition.
You ready?
Okay.
The one condition is
that the night that I launch it,
you get your entire family,
all those six daughters
of yours, together,
you throw a huge party...
(chuckles)
And you hoot and Holler
and drink a huge glass
of Champagne
when you see
that "Sold out" sign
come up on air.
All right.
I have an offer for you.
That would work.
I'll give you
the $50,000 for 40%.
Then I'll just call her.
(laughs)
(mark laughs) Yeah.
I don't know. This sounds
like a personal thing.
But he's not gonna get it
on air immediately...
(laughs)
I'll just go
to their competitor.
And he doesn't have
the following,
the millions of viewers.
I'll just go to--
I'll just go
to their competitor.
There's another one that
does this, too.
Barbara, I r--I rarely--
No, no. Let me jump in.
I rarely say this,
but sometimes it's better
to own 49% of something
that's selling
than 100% of a pure idea.
Exactly.
(Kevin) he's not writing you
a check.
It's very interesting advice.
It's exactly worth that--
Nothing.
Very interesting moment for you.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Two sharks are out,
and Barbara has two offers
on the table,
one from Lori
and one from Kevin.
(Lori) Let me tell you
one thing first.
I treat all of my products
as though they were my babies,
and I put my heart and soul
into everything.
I will treat your products
exactly like one of my own,
and that means, actually,
that I will watch even closer,
because I will feel responsible
to you
and to your making back
your $300,000
and to you being
really successful,
so all of that will go
into what I do.
Tv ladies are
a dime a dozen.
There's many competitor--
Ohh.
Excuse me. Let me say
what I want to say.
That's so not True.
There's lots--
Look, I'm just speaking
the truth here.
There's lots of people
that can get you
on shopping channels,
because there's more than one.
That is so wrong.
That's what makes
America great.
There's more than one.
There's always competition,
so the decision you have
to make, Barbara, is,
should you give up control
of your baby?
51%.
(chuckles)
I love that. "Baby."
That means the decisions
are no longer one
that you make alone, okay?
Right.
I don't need to have control
in this situation,
because I totally trust
your decision-Making.
You've got it here.
I'm a financial investor.
You need money.
Now what I'm prepared to do is
give you the same offer for 40%.
Then I'll call
the shopping channels with you.
Done that before, so lots--
and they'll hang up
when they hear him.
Well, maybe this one will,
or maybe another buyer will
understand the opportunity,
and we'll go to them.
I've sold lots of stuff
on shopping channels
in my career,
all kinds of products,
from children's software...
and it works.
I know how to do it.
Now, daymond,
you've got retail.
You wanna come in with me
on this?
(Lori scoffs)
I've been in the shopping world,
shopping channel world,
for 15 years.
You talk like it's nothing.
Most people fail that
go on, but--
not me. I don't fail.
Yeah, you will fail.
But, see, we don't--
We don't--We don't fail--
You know nothing about
nail polish.
Wait a minute.
I'm not gonna sell it.
Wait, Wait, Wait,
wait, wait.
I've been on for 15 years.
I'm not gonna sell it.
Barbara's gonna sell it.
You can't just call up
a buyer and say, "hey..."
No.
We just take the 10,000 units,
put it into duty-Free,
and then license the rest
to avon,
and we won't need
a shopping channel,
so--
And they talk like it's so easy,
and you know it's not.
Yeah, that's 'cause we've
done it before.
We've done it before.
I'm sorry. We've done it.
You--You know what?
We've done it before.
Sorry. You have not.
I know all about qvc...
we've done it before.
And I know the success rate.
All right.
Big deal.
I've been doing retail
for 25 years...
you don't know how to sell
on tv, daymond.
And branding.
I've forgotten more
than she has learned.
I'm not worried about that.
That is not--
Oh, come on.
I couldn't care less
about that.
If you want to deal
with financial guys...
the issue is that--
That smoke cigarettes
and drink scotch and talk
about the markets--
You know what, honestly?
(daymond)
Uh, listen, listen, listen.
(laughs)
a piggy bank
with two Nickels in it
makes way more noise
than a full piggy bank,
and I have a lot...
(laughing)
Oh, my god.
Of knowledge.
That's a great one.
My piggy Bank is as full
as his piggy bank.
That was nasty.
You want to do the deal
at 40%?
(sighs)
Negotiate, Barbara.
Well, the--the 51%...
You've got the leverage.
Does scare me.
I'm just...
(speaks indistinctly)
And you should be scared.
What do you offer back
to me, Barbara?
I like the 40%.
I like--I like you.
You want 40%?
You seem like a lovely lady,
and I like the idea
of the big party
and all of us girls.
Wow.
All right.
I'll give you $50,000. 40%.
Don't do it, Barbara.
Done. You have to ignore them.
They don't exist anymore.
You don't have to do
anything.
Right now. Say yes, and it'll be
on qvc within months.
Yes.
Done. Good job, Lori.
Wow. Bang!
Oh, she got you, O'Leary.
(Kevin) No, she didn't.
She got you.
She had to come down
to my price.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(speaks indistinctly)
I hope so.
I promise you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
(Robert) Yeah, she--
Congratulations, Barbara.
Congrats.
Thank you, everybody.
Way to go, Lori.
Good job, Lori.
Whoo! Oh, yeah.
Well, I want you all
to know,
I think that product's gonna
be huge. (chuckles)
you do, seriously?
Huge.
It's going to be everywhere...
why hasn't somebody
done this?
Like that.
Everybody says, "Oh, this is
the greatest idea in the world.
Why didn't I think of that?"
because they didn't.
Because she did.
♪♪♪
Earlier this season,
we watched Shane Talbott
and Steve nakisher
strike a deal
with Kevin O'Leary
for their company,
Talbott teas,
a designer tea brand.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
This is absolutely great.
I'm not kidding.
Thank you.
Let's go sell some tea.
(both) All right.
(man)
Let's see where they're at now.
(Steve) Our experience
with "Shark tank"
has been life-Changing.
Absolutely amazing things
have been happening
to us ever since.
(all) Hey! Welcome to jamba!
Daymond And Barbara ended up
joining forces with Kevin
and connected us
to jamba juice.
And jamba juice liked
our business so much,
they ended up buying
the entire company.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
What's happening?
Hey, daymond.
(Shane) today we're meeting
at our new home...
(Steve) and all the key players
are gonna be there--
Kevin, daymond,
James white,
the c.E.O. Of jamba juice.
We're very excited.
Welcome to the team.
(Shane) Thank you so much.
We're thrilled
to have you here.
And I'm gonna stay on as
vice president of innovations,
where I'll continue
to create all-New products.
Now the bottom line is
these two guys are rich now.
(chuckles)
"Shark tank" Made you rich.
'fess up.
We can't disclose
the actual amount of our deal,
but we can say that
we are very, very happy.
And "Shark tank" Has
made us rich.
Steve, look.
(laughs)
Oh, my God.
Look how great this looks.
Wow.
(Shane) Talbott teas will be
in the jamba juice stores
coming Very soon This year.
Talbott teas
and jamba juice.
Oh, yeah.
(all) cheers.
To a bright future.
A bright future.
♪♪♪
(man) Next up is Debbie Brooks
And Paul D'auriac
with a line of artful
and versatile accessories.
Hi, sharks.
My name Is Paul D'auriac.
And I'm Debbie Brooks,
and we are the owners
of Debbie Brooks handbags,
a unique handbag line
based on my original artwork,
and we are seeking $540,000
in exchange
for a 20% equity position
in our company.
Debbie and I met
on a blind date.
Our first reaction was...
(laughs)
You're not my type.
Fast-Forward 15 years.
Debbie and I are married
to each other.
We have a beautiful baby girl
and, of course, our business.
When we first met, I got fired
from my job, so I said to him,
"I'm gonna come work for you,
'cause if we end up together,
"you'd better make a lot
of money,
'cause now I'm
a starving artist."
So I went to work for him,
selling air conditioning
and refrigeration service
contracts door-To-Door.
But I knew art was
her passion,
so I gave her a check
for $5,000 for christmas
to buy a Booth
at upcoming artexpo New York,
and that's how we launched
the art business.
Then one day,
money got a little tight,
and I couldn't afford to go
shopping for a new handbag,
so I made one,
and a woman loved it
and chased me
through an airport.
She said, "where did you get
that fabulous bag?"
and, sharks, we have some
of those items
for you to look at.
This one we made
for Gwyneth paltrow.
That's one of my favorites.
(daymond) Mm.
This one we made
just for you in mind.
Oh, my goodness.
That's nice.
Oh, that's cool.
(Paul) So I thought,
if that crazy woman
in the airport
loved Debbie's bag
so much,
maybe we should take this
to a retailer,
so we took our line
to henri bendel's
on fifth Avenue,
and that's where we launched
the handbag collection.
Now through all of this,
there's one thing I learned
about women.
Just one?
Just one.
(chuckles)
Women need a different look
to match
every single outfit
they own.
That is why I came up
with the magna fab concept,
short for "Magna fabulous."
Well, this is how they work.
You just push down,
and they're all magnetic.
We are grateful
for the success we've had today,
and we believe, together,
with your involvement,
we can make "Debbie Brooks"
a household name.
(Robert) What's the business?
Are we buying into
just that handbag with that
or all of it?
It's the entire
Debbie Brooks brand.
And we also have two patents.
And what do you want
the money for?
Basically,
our main distribution channel
right now is
jewelry stores.
We're in 1,000 jewelry stores
across the country.
We are typically the first
and only accessory item sold
in these stores.
Because of the economy,
they've been very receptive
to our product category,
and our sell-Through in
that jewelry store environment
has been remarkable.
So the $540,000 is to do
a little bit more
of what we're doing already.
Okay, But, Paul,
the valuation of the business--
You're asking me
for $540,000 for 20%--
We're about $2.7 million
in value.
Exactly.
Make me excited
that that's a good deal.
$1.2 million is
our gross sales for the company.
Our gross profit is
$685,000.
What does a purse like
this cost?
That's
a $288 retail price point.
And what'd it cost you
to make?
So wholesale cost on that
is $130 wholesale.
Markup at retail is 2.2.
(Robert) So is that a lot, Paul?
Like, I-I don't know.
To an average woman--
Actually, it's--
It's very comfortable.
It's incredibly comfortable.
Are you guys familiar with
a brand called "Judith leiber"?
I'm sure you are.
(Lori) Yes.
Okay.
Yes.
That was a $2,000 to $3,000
to $5,000 retail price point.
But they're
all swarovski crystals.
They are
swarovski crystals.
Which--
Correct.
Which justifies
that enormous price point.
The secret
to our success is,
we're selling
in a high-End environment,
so the initial perception
of our line in that environment
is these should be $1,000.
So, Paul, $288 is high-End?
Comfortable price point
in a jewelry store environment.
All right,
so I-I don't want to--
correct.
And that's why you're
in jewelry stores, right?
(Debbie) Yes. Exactly.
Precisely.
Because the perception is
completely different.
Yeah. You got it.
You're not in--
It augments the perception.
Y-You're not head-to-Head
with everybody else
and every other purse,
right?
Exactly.
Jewelry stores are having
a tough time right now
because their entry level
price points are very high.
They need something that's gonna
bring in a new customer
and that's gonna build
a collector base
and get them back
into that store.
That's why they love
our line,
and that's why we've had
tremendous success
with the line.
As a woman, do you like it?
Do you hate it? You don't want
to hurt their feelings?
No, I don't hate it.
I like some of them,
but here's
what I'm struggling with.
The only thing, to me,
that is unique and different
is the interchangeability
of your magnet.
Exactly.
And I'd like to understand
your patent or patents.
We created
this fabrication medium,
3-Dimensional
fabrication medium.
Of that process,
it's entirely patented
by a utility process.
Now we have
a second patent, okay,
which applies
to the adhesion aspect
of the magna fab,
the removal aspect.
So it is the Click-On
and Click-Off.
Precisely. Precisely.
Anybody else can make
a magnet
that fits on the front
of a purse.
You could make a look
that's similar,
but you can't make
this identical look...
I don't think anybody cares.
Without infringing
on our patent.
I-I think there's
a million other ways to do that.
I'm out.
Before you were talking
about patents,
you were talking
about numbers.
Precisely.
Get me back there.
Okay.
28% up 2011 from 2010.
No, But just give me
the forecast for 2011.
Now I did a one--
Top-Line dollars.
$1.6 million.
What am I gonna make on it?
Uh, at least $400,000 net.
Paul, why are you here?
Why do you need the $540,000?
We're ready to take the company
to the next level.
One-Third of that
we wanna put into
direct to consumer advertising.
A third of that
into trade advertising.
The final third would be to
increase our inventory levels,
which are currently
at $240,000.
As we continue
to build the brand
and the name recognition
improves,
okay, there are
huge licensing opportunities.
But that's a long shot.
You know, that's p--
That's a long shot.
I'm not a purse guy, obviously.
Not even a murse guy.
Not even a murse guy?
(Robert) What's a murse, mark?
A man purse. Murse.
Um... (chuckles)
Wow.
(Lori laughs)
I like the fact
that you're selling
in jewelry stores, right?
You go where they ain't.
I think that's brilliant.
But at the same time,
I just don't think
that I can add the value
that you would need.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Um, so...
Debbie, I-I...
I'm not really sure what--
what you're selling today.
The brand in its entirety.
We wanna build the brand.
(Robert) I...
y-You know, I found it
a little confusing just for me,
maybe because I'm not a...
what did mark call it?
A man purse?
A murse person, yes.
(Debbie) a murse.
A metrosexual.
(laughs)
(Robert) Yeah, maybe I'm not
a murse enough guy.
But I found the presentation
a little confusing.
I'm not really sure
what's in the business.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out.
Kevin and Lori are
Debbie and Paul's last chance
to make a deal.
Uh, Paul... and Debbie...
I like cash flow.
Me, too.
Love it. I like the way
it rolls off my lips.
That's why we're
in jewelry stores.
I love it.
Cash flow. So...
I look at the cash flow you've
got, and I say to myself,
in your industry--
Fashion--
Would anybody ever pay
9.5 times Free cash flow?
And I don't think they would.
Can I interrupt
a quick second?
You may.
If you're not taking
into account the patent,
the I.P.
--
I think your valuation is...
100% too much.
You have to cut this in half.
And having said all that,
I love Debbie's designs...
thank you.
And I will pay you for this.
I'll buy this...
we figured you'd like
that one.
Because it says,
"you're dead to me,"
and you are,
'cause I'm out.
I think you've got
a lot of patent issues here.
I'm not really trusting
what your patent is all about.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Well, thank you very much
for your time.
Thank you.
(mark) Thanks, guys. Good luck.
(Lori) Good luck.
Actually, the patent wasn't
even to sell.
The patent didn't cover
anything.
No.
There's a lot of great product
out there,
and these aren't unique.
That's the bottom line.
Lori was very interested
in our patent.
I hope that doesn't mean
she's gonna go home
and knock us off now.
She couldn't.
She sells bags for $20.
Whoa.
♪♪♪
Next up are Nicole Bilski
and Lindsay Johnson,
pittsburgh hockey moms
with a fashion statement
they make at home.
Hi. My name's Nicole Bilski.
And I'm Lindsay Johnson.
Our company is trimi tank.
We feature the only tank top
on the market
with interchangeable
removable straps.
We are seeking
a $57,000 investment...
(chuckles)
for a 30% stake in our company.
(mouths word)
We are
two pittsburgh hockey moms...
There ya go. Go, pens!
Who came up
with this concept
at our sons' 6:00 a.M.
Hockey practice.
Each trimi tank comes with
three sets of straps
that you get to choose.
You can choose to layer them
or mix and match them
or simply just wear
one at a time.
The straps are super easy
to come on and off.
And they come in so many
different varieties.
There's jewelry straps,
ribbon straps,
funky straps,
any kind of...
and you're good to go.
Any strap you could imagine.
Currently, we are handmaking
each strap
and selling the tanks
in our homes.
Can I see the--
the, um, the tops, please?
Sure.
Absolutely.
In the future, we're hoping
that these straps
could then be interchanged
throughout a whole wardrobe.
Thank you.
So they could go from
your shirt to your dress,
like Lindsay's wearing today.
How many have you sold?
We have sold approximately 100.
To date.
100,000?
No, 100.
Oh.
1-0-0.
So many dollars is that?
100 units.
Well...
well, right now,
they're retailing for $35.
We're retailing them for $35.
That's $3,500 worth of sales.
Yes.
You don't need to think about
what we've done.
You need to think about
what it could be.
How far we've got--
How far it could go.
Yeah, baby! That's right.
That's the pittsburgh spirit,
right?
(Nicole) And where it can go.
Where it can go!
Bec--I mean, really.
I'm gonna ask you
a-a cold, hard truth here.
Sure.
Okay.
When you showed these around
to people,
did you do
any market research,
ask people what
they thought of it?
Yes.
We have done a craft show,
a huge--Well, not a huge--
But a flea market in pittsburgh.
And have gone to other, like,
handmade markets.
Small venues that we could
just get into.
Small markets.
And how did women react
to this?
Do you know what they say?
They say,
"that is the coolest idea.
Why didn't I think of that?"
and they always say, "you should
be on that 'shark tank' show."
(laughs)
And did they buy it?
They--That's exactly what
they said.
Did they buy it?
At the time, we had no means
of accepting credit cards,
and...
and we were in the wrong spot.
How many women
at that flea market...
you guys are, like,
the best friends.
Wanted to buy this?
(Lindsay and Nicole) We are!
They are!
Apparently none.
They $3,500 in sales.
Shh!
Yeah, but I-I-I just wanna know
the number.
I would say...
approximately... 50?
A lot of them said they didn't
have any money.
A lot of them have commented--
They asked if we...
they weren't there
to buy clothes...
had them on--Online.
Because we were
at a flea market.
It was...
they were buying fruit
that day.
When you're saying that you were
at a flea market,
and people really actually
didn't buy it.
They instead bought the fruit
or they instead bought
something else.
That's kind of a little bit
of a wake-Up call
that this might not be
your homerun.
I'm out.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
Guys, since y'all are from
the 'burgh, right?
I love seeing Pittsburgh people
be entrepreneurs
and--And attack a business.
Um, we can go drink
some I.C. Light, have a--
You know what?
Just a minute, mark.
You can target specific groups.
Right.
I mean, we could go
into a sorority
and just have sorority letters
on them.
You can--We have
awareness ribbons.
You can go and do--
Look, I-I like the hustle.
I like the energy.
I like the vision, even.
But it's not an area where
I have a lot of expertise.
I couldn't tell you one good
tank top from another.
And as much as I wanna see
you guys become successful,
I just can't help you,
so I have to be out.
Thank you, though. We'll take
you up on those I.C.S.
(laughs)
(Robert) Daymond?
(speaks indistinctly)
(laughs)
You know what? I saw it
in flea markets as well.
And, uh, I couldn't keep
the inventory.
I just couldn't keep it. I would
just keep blowing out of it.
I would buy, you know,
200 shirts here,
then I'd come back with 1,000,
and--
Daymond, This would look great
with a pair of fubu jeans.
Yeah.
You know it would. It would.
No, I understand
what you're saying,
but you're too early of a stage
for me to help you
or even to understand if there's
a business to help you.
So...
Mm-hmm.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
(Robert) You know, you sold 100.
It's a risk.
It's a chance for you to get in
at the ground level and--
It's way too soon.
It's a Hobby.
You haven't--you haven't
proved the market yet.
It's there, though.
It really, really is.
It really is there.
Good pitch, great energy,
but I'm out.
Okay.
Ohh, and you!
Now we're down to one shark.
You know...
you're the best!
All roads lead--Ohh!
(Robert laughs)
Listen, listen.
Nicole, that was great.
Ladies.
(laughs)
All roads to lead
to Mr. Wonderful in the end.
So here's my offer to you.
We go to a fine restaurant.
I let you choose any bottle
on the list that's worth $3,500,
which is equal to your sales.
When dinner's over,
we burn it all.
How can we let you
kill our baby like that?
This is not a good idea.
I'm out.
I think you guys are
really missing out
on a great opportunity.
You'll see.
Oh, I know. I know.
People love these.
I'm not worried about it.
You'll see, pittsburgh boy.
People love these.
Just rock 'n' roll.
Just go with it.
(singsongy)
See you for dinner!
Ah!
Oh!
(Robert) Never good when a shark
says, "see you for dinner."
(sharks Laughing)
♪♪♪
Next up is Mark and Hanna Lim
with a product
inspired by their children.
Hi, my name is Mark Lim,
this is my beautiful wife Hanna,
and we are the founders
of lollacup.
We are here today seeking
a $100,000 investment
for a 15% equity stake
in our company.
When our first daughter
was only 9 months old,
our pediatrician wanted us
to use straw cups
rather than
the traditional sippys
because of the speech and dental
benefits of using straws.
I must've tried every
toddler straw cup on the market
only to find that most of them
had spill-Proof valves,
like these, that made them
incredibly hard
for her to drink from.
Cleaning them was
even more frustrating.
And unlike all the adorable
baby products out there,
these cups were
just not cute.
So mark and I set out to create
a stylish cup
that both kids
and their parents would love.
As parents ourselves, safety is
really our number one concern.
That's why we decided
to manufacture the product
here in the United States,
so we could be sure
we'd have a quality product
made with safe plastics.
I've seen so many toddlers
struggle with straw cups,
so we designed lollacup to
eliminate all the challenges.
You don't know how many times
my daughter has done this
with her straws
and asked me for more milk,
simply because the straw
was lodged up here
and the liquid was resting
down at the bottom.
Lollacup's weighted straw
keeps it in the liquid,
so children can actually drink
even when the cup is tilted.
The handles
make it easy to hold
But they detach
with a simple twist,
so you can put it in
a cup Holder or diaper bag.
Last but not least,
lollacup is easy to clean.
We are confident that we have
a great product that sells.
We hope you'll join us
with your expertise and funding
to help take lollacup
to the next level.
So do you have sales today
or is that a prototype?
Yes. In the four months
that we've been shipping,
we have 30,000 in sales,
5,000 on order,
and we have a soft order
of $30,000 for the holiday.
How much do you sell them for
into retail?
The retail price is $18,
it wholesales at $9,
and it costs us $4.50 to make.
What does
a normal sippy cup cost?
Anywhere from $5 to $6,
upwards of $25 plus.
And if you were
making these overseas,
how much would your cost
to manufacture them be?
I think if we made them
overseas,
they could probably be made
for about $2, $2,50.
And you're paying how much?
$4.50.
If we were to go
that overseas route,
which really, we don't want to
because we feel like--
I mean, I can't tell you
the number of times
I've been in a baby store
and women literally
walk in and say,
"show me every product here
that's not made in China."
Why do you make the assumption
that a chinese-Made product
in today's global economy
is poorly made?
You know, I'm not making
that assumption.
It's just what
I've personally heard.
And, you know,
the women I've spoken to,
the moms that we hang out with,
they're really looking for
the U.S.A.-,
european-Made products.
'cause I'm having a hard time
paying more than 10 bucks
for a sippy cup.
Yeah, having--Let me just
tell you, I agree with you.
There's just absolutely
no reason
to put your kids' health at risk
over $3.
And I like the weighted, um,
straw idea because
my little son all the time,
you know, doing this...
you know, so I get that.
But the real question
I have is,
have you tried to go to
the bigger box stores?
And what was their response?
Well, we've actually been
approached by several, um,
big box retailers.
We took our prototypes again
to a trade show
last october, and--
What, uh, what big box store?
Um, babies "R" us.
Let me guess. They said it was
way too expensive.
They actually didn't talk much
about price point.
Their main concern was
the packaging.
(mark) What didn't they like?
(Robert) What's wrong
with the packaging?
Yeah,
what didn't they like?
They didn't--
I think it took
too much real estate,
and so they wanted
to change the--
No, it's not stackable.
That's the problem.
Right.
And they didn't--
they said that you couldn't see
the entire product.
That can be fixed.
All that can be fixed.
(Robert) Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out
what it is
that moves millions of units.
Because I've raised two kids.
Sippy cups are a mandatory item.
You have
a better mousetrap here.
What's the price point
that blows it out
so that every American family
can afford it?
I would say $10 to $12.
Okay. So if we have to
sell it at $9.99,
which is a very popular
retail price point...
Mm-hmm.
You gotta make it
for a buck 70.
Right.
Is that your girls there
in the picture,
those adorable girls?
Yes. We have two. (laughs)
Yeah. (laughs)
And do they use the cup
and they--Do they love it?
Yeah, they love it.
They think of it as a toy
when they first see it.
Oh, Hanna, can I see it?
But--Yeah.
Of course. We have some--
Did you create this yourself?
Did you think of this idea?
(mark l.) Yes.
Yeah.
Oh, I love the colors.
The two of you together
or...
um, you know, I mean, I'm the
mom who uses it the most.
So I came with the concept,
but we did work on it together.
(Robert) Thank you.
(Lori) I love your dedication,
and I think that This is
really ingenious
and a great product.
Thank you.
Tell me a little bit
about your story.
Tell me about
the two of you.
Well, mark and I actually
started dating
in the seventh grade.
(laughs) Oh!
So we actually--We got married
14 years later.
(Lori) Wow.
And we started a family
pretty soon after that.
And we think about our daughters
now, we're like,
"no way. We do not want them
dating anyone in seventh grade."
(laughs) Well, if she finds
a nice guy like me,
the I think I'd... (laughs)
So how much have you invested
in this?
We invested, uh, $100,000.
(daymond) okay.
And the--the money went towards
product development...
uh-Huh, casting. I got it.
Industrial design, molds.
And there's a patent
on this?
Yes. We actually just got
an e-mail today,
this morning, that we were
issued the patent.
Congratulations.
(Lori) It's a utility patent?
It's a design patent.
Design patent.
Design. Uh, $100,000...
right.
For 15% means you're putting
the company's value
at a half a million dollars,
around...
right.
So we've signed with a sales rep
to cover the U.S.,
just two, three weeks ago.
Exclusivity?
Pardon?
Did you give them
exclusivity?
Yes, we did, for one year.
Did they give you minimums?
Um, minimum as in--
In other words,
what guarantee do you have
that they'll sell it?
Well, there's no guarantee.
What happens
if they don't sell any?
And you're stuck with them
as the exclusive for one year.
Well ,you know, Hanna and I--
You should never
do a deal like that.
Right.
There's no performance metrics
in that deal?
They said they--We expected
150 to 200 accounts.
Yeah, talk is cheap.
I expect that, too.
Right.
But if they don't deliver,
what happens?
Well, I mean,
if they don't deliver,
we have, you know, I mean--
Guess what.
You'll never do a deal
like that again.
You're gonna learn
the hard way.
(mark) Where are you guys
selling these now?
Which stores?
What kind of stores?
Mostly baby stores,
kids clothing stores...
baby stores.
And some gift shops even.
And--And where are
you holding
the inventory that you have
for this?
(mark and Hanna) In our garage.
(chuckles)
In your garage, huh?
And you guys have been
shipping them yourselves?
Oh, that's a nighttime activity.
Yeah. (laughs)
You don't even know.
Right now, we don't sleep.
We assemble cups
in our living room.
I love this.
I think this is a great idea.
It's really not my market,
and, um, so I wish you
the best of luck with it,
but I'm out.
Let me just start things off
with an offer,
because this is
the new sippy cup.
I agree with you. You've done
a fantastic job.
My offer's contingent.
I'm gonna give you $100,000
for 50% of the company.
You have to source this
offshore
and get the price
below 2 bucks
to make this work.
Then we're going to sell
millions of them.
What do you want to do?
♪♪♪
One shark is out.
Hanna and mark have an offer
from Kevin O'Leary,
but his offer comes with
the contingency
of lowering costs,
which may compromise their
"made in America" principle.
What do you want to do?
Are there, uh, any offers
that are being entertained?
Tell me more about
your, um, sales agent
and what your deal us.
As I said,
we just signed with them.
And so they're
in a trade show right now.
What I'm trying
to figure out is,
all right you able to continue
to go out and sell?
Are we able
What are your limitations
and what are your opportunities?
I mean, there's no limitations.
There--We--We still go sell.
I mean, we--we don't wait
for them. And they--they don't--
Now do you have to run that sale
back through the sales agent?
Right now, yes.
Okay, and what do you have
to pay the sales agent?
We're paying them 15%.
Wow. Is that for a specific
geographic area?
Uh. It's just--It's the U.S.
The entire U.S. Right now.
Yes.
Mm-Hmm.
Uh, let me just go a little bit
sideways for a second.
I've been--I've been an investor
in, uh, this sector for a while,
and my, uh, my heinie Kicked
pretty badly.
Here's what I learned about
the baby niche market like this.
To make any real money,
you've gotta go
to general distribution,
like every other product.
What's your thought on that?
I think our sales strategy
really--
which we've seen in products
that we end up buying
at target--
We see them in the hands
of trendsetters
and tastemakers first,
and that's where we want them.
And then eventually, we see them
coming down to target,
and then we do it.
I don't disagree
with the strategy,
especially since the obstacle
I see is the sales agent.
Okay.
I don't wanna help you
go get that $10 million order
tomorrow,
or million-Unit order,
and have to give 15%
off the top of that,
of the work that we did,
right.
Right.
I've had the industrial designer
wanna invest.
I've--Our manufacturer
wants to invest.
My--My--
So if they all wanna invest,
you've been walking away
from money to come here?
I wanna play with winners.
I wanna be with guys that I know
will--Will help us--
But you have an offer
on the table.
You don't have to leave
with nothing.
Right.
You're waiting for somebody else
to step up. It seems no one has.
I['m interested in a deal.
I'm gonna match
Voldemort's deal.
$100,000 for 15%
of the company,
contingent that you can get out
of your sales agreement deal.
Okay.
I don't have that contingency.
I'll meet with that person
and motivate them myself
my own special way.
(laughs)
(laughs) I'm sure you will.
Um, and, daymond, are you--
is this the same requirements--
We take the price point down,
do an overseas
manufacturing-Type thing?
If you can get
the price point down
and Buybuy baby says, "listen,
I'll put it in my circular,"
I'll--We'll let them dictate it.
We just may not get an order.
Okay.
And then we'll have to
decide from there.
(mark l.) okay.
It is really about
this--This agent.
Mark, what are you doing here?
Trying to figure out
what I'm gonna do.
You know, not all deals
are easy.
You know, guys, the sales agency
thing is problematic,
but it's the past.
It's happened.
You gotta let that run out.
In--In eight short months.
In eight short months.
(laughs) In eight sh--Now when
you write a check for $100,000,
there's no such thing
as eight short months. Yeah.
(Lori) Yeah.
Mark, you know that
the value is wrong.
You know the value's wrong.
Why don't you throw
another number back at me?
I mean, these offers are
ridiculous. You know that.
Right.
But why don't you throw
a number back at me?
These offers are not ridiculous.
'cause they're real offers.
No real offer's ridiculous.
You know that.
(exhales deeply)
okay. Um...
would you be willing to do
$100,000 for 40%?
Yes. Done.
(chuckles)
Shake on it?
(Lori laughs)
Do we have a deal?
Well, I, you know,
I have to respect...
'cause we're--He just
asked me a question...
(Kevin) Not so fast.
So I to respect... (laughs)
(Hanna laughs)
Sit down.
(daymond) Sit down!
Get back on the bench!
Just one shot. One shot.
(mark c.) if I walk back here...
This is--This is
a-a one-Shot deal?
One-Shot deal.
(daymond) Can I--
can we get two seconds
to talk to my wife?
You can talk all you want,
but if I walk back there...
right.
Can you stand there then
for about...
(sharks laughs)
Please. Respectfully.
About 30 seconds?
You know what?
I'm a basketball guy.
Right.
I'm gonna give you
a 24-Second clock.
24 seconds. Okay.
(Robert) Mark,
do you really--Really--
How rude is that?
Right.
I'm not even finished talking,
and the guy gets up.
I mean.... mark...
right.
15 seconds left.
I'll do the same deal--30%.
(Lori) Oh, you've got
all these offers.
(Kevin) Whoa!
Well, hang on.
What happened there?
I just said I'll do
the same deal for 30%.
Hey, wait a second.
I just beat mark's deal.
Right.
Did you just undercut mark
and...
yep.
And the offer I was gonna...
I don't know your offer.
You keep mumbling over there.
Well, I-I was gonna accept
the offer at $100,000 for 40%,
and then mark just got up
and, uh...
how about this? Would you--
your deal's over?
Mark, would you be willing
to work with Robert?
Because, really, we would really
like your expertise.
(daymond) guys, I gave you
a great offer.
Hey! I gave you a great offer,
but you took too long,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Mark, would you be willing
to go in with Robert?
Because we would love to have
both of your expertise.
I thought when you sat down,
it was over.
Sometimes I reconsider.
Um, for 40%?
Yes.
Robert,
are you cool with that?
(mark c. And Lori laugh)
Come on, Robert. It's 40%.
That means 50k for each of us,
20% for each of us.
I'm in.
All right. Okay.
First, gotta shake your hand.
There you go.
All right, man. Yeah.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Good job, guys. Thank you.
(Lori) Love your parenting.
Good luck.
Good job, man.
(mark l. And Hanna Laughing)
Thank you. Thanks.
We're gonna be awesome.
Hanna, you could've hugged me,
you didn't have to hug mark.
(laughs)
I-I have exclusivity here.
You know... (laughs)
(sharks laughing)
Oh, they're great.
They're a great couple.
I mean, right at this moment,
I--We're on cloud nine.
But I think it's just motivation
to work even Harder.
Right.